das war wirklich eine wunderbare frau
speicher kompliment an die kirche
natürlich auch an sich das hat alles
giotto gekocht ich hab nur ein bisschen
geholfen
das ist wahrscheinlich auch prima und
wasserball punkt jetzt wollen wir nicht
erst noch einmal anstoßen
schließlich wollte ich mich ja noch mal
bei euch allen bedanken und mich
entschuldigen
kommt lasst uns anschluss auf uns große
salut salon oder eine entschuldigung
das sage ich dir nach dem hauptgang lena
und ich müsste noch mal schnell in die
küche ist bestimmt von rich immer noch
nichts gesagt
ich hatte noch keine gelegenheit
außerdem redet er ja auch nicht ja
leider
ich glaub er mag mich nicht quatsch er
starrt dich doch die ganze zeit an
ja und das macht mag bei dir auch
ehrlich
also du sowas sonst habe ich noch nie
gegessen und ich war am anfang dagegen
bist du eins ist aber er ist nicht alles
zurück wenn du versprichst öfter zu
kommen sehr gerne und reeser die das
programm ohne planung geschmeckt
schokoladensauce so scharf sein kann zu
verlängern
ist das echt brasilianischen ein
mexikanischer aber ich koche gerne
international persisch hatte ich
allerdings vorher noch nie probiert nur
für dich leser und das macht jahren war
wunderbar so einen leckeren kuchen nur
gut habe ich noch nie gegessen
es ist der von meiner mutter aber wofür
sie sich eigentlich bei mir entschuldigt
ich habe doch vor kurzem diesen unfall
gemacht mit marx taxi genauso ist in den
lack zerkratzten mit einem fahrrad
aber das ist nicht so schlimm ehrlich
und weist über ganz fantastisch
fahrräder reparieren kann und die helfen
wird das alles wieder in ordnung zu
bringen
lena